This first option is the one that makes us happy.
Higher precedence means it gets done first.
It's on the inside of the parentheses, so I really need this part
with the colon, -1--that has to be inside all the parentheses,
and not len. This is the wrong approach.
And then associates to the left means that
we typically want our parentheses to look like this--
they're grouped off to the left as much as possible.
So here we have 1, 2, 3--we remove one element,
and then we remove one element from the rest of it, and then we compute the length.
Here we are in the Python interpreter, and I'm just going to show you that
this subrange operator actually does associate to the left in Python.
Here I have more or less two versions of the same expression,
where taking 1, 2, 3--chopping off all but the last element--
chopping off all but the last element again.
So our list is going to go down from three elements to two elements to one.
Here I have the original expression, and here I have the original expression with added parentheses,
and we look down and see that they both get the same answer.